like i said i did a variety show i did
one acting class
and then i was an improv i had very
little experience like in formal
training yet you know what i mean so
then you started to fall in love with us
i fell in love with improv which just
made me like chase it forever the idea
of creating and writing on your feet was
just mystical to me and that led me into
theater when i graduated and i was doing
psychology for the first couple years
right out of college what were you doing
in psychology i worked on an adolescent
psych ward northwestern hospital with
disturbed adolescents for two years and
i was taking like graduate school i was
thinking i was gonna be a psychologist
what was that like
it was intense it was it was really
educational and intense like a lot of
disturbed kids a lot of uh medication
that was like you know this is like 1989
let's say so like early
ritalin and early zoloft and they're
experimenting with drugs to get kids
normalized and then you'd see
schizophrenia or you'd see eating
disorders or you see kids with suicide
or you'd see like court-ordered
gang bangers who's you know the judge
says you can either go to psyche val or
you can go to prison juvie and they're
like i'll go to psyche val and then you
know so you get every kind of population
in there
wealthy
poor public aid kids you know
rockefeller kids essentially like so you
got everything in there so it was
fascinating 100 percent
something that was too challenging that
once i was exposed to i'm like this is
too hard it was too much for you yeah
you didn't want to do it anymore because
the responsibility of helping someone
is too great like if you mess that up
they could kill themselves or they could
it could go really wrong like if you
misdiagnose if you don't get because you
saw it as i was just like on the nursing
staff as a mental health worker kind of
working my way up to like be a
psychologist i wasn't really doing
treatment plans for anyone but you
process emotion with every kid and you
try to treat them therapeutically it's
like a camp counselor vibe you know it
was draining so draining because you're
awash with pathology when you come home
at the end of the day
so that would do that during the day
and then at night i would go out and do
comedy in bars
so i had like two livestreams yeah like
two i was living two days i would it was
crazy and you what was the first
the first time you felt like i'm funny
i've got this i am i how many classes in
what what happened where you felt like
i've got to go full throttle and what
did you do
the the bug or the juice that hit me or
the crack
was like i don't know three or four
classes into my first level one in
private players workshop i ended up
doing a scene with who became a friend
of mine this guy kevin ervick
and we like sustained a three-minute
scene that made everyone in the class
laughed and it was as if we were able to
finish each other's sentences and it's
as if we knew
where the scene was going and that to me
was mind-blowing like i couldn't imagine
how that happened and so i was chasing
that i was trying to understand how to
do that again
right and what when did i mean how many
years later did uh did ucb start
uh ucb probably started loosely a couple
years later like in various incarnations
and then
the four of us moved to new york and
that was amy poehler amy poehler matt
besser ian roberts and myself right
um
and then we moved to new york in like 96
in 96 and then i met michael
and then my life changed you met me you
met me in the office yeah i met you in
the office and you were like getting
coffee for dave miner i think at the
time
i probably was these uh and these guys
represent a lot of comedy studs now are
you who are you with now
uh i just have an agent i don't have a
manager anymore yeah no managers became
it's like what do you need you need a
manager do you have a manager no no but
i for years i had a manager fifteen
percent an agent ten percent i published
this five percent a lawyer five percent
it's like what am i making any money
here i know i don't have a manager but i
do have i need an accountant like a i'm
terrible that way and i need
occasionally i get a publicist if i have
to promote something right and then an
age you need an agent you don't you must
have anything i have an agent yeah you
have to have an agent
you